[Music]
our rural area in small settlements or
Tartu hot water - were being a new one
rural areas currently make up the
majority of the district and agriculture
and rural economy play a major part in
creating wealth employment and character
the Waimakariri district has one of the
largest lifestyle bloc populations of
any district in the country we need to
be mindful what further lifestyle
developments may impact on large-scale
productive land use and the character of
the rural area
[Music]
the district also features small rural
towns and settlement these are diverse
in both location and character and we
need to think carefully about what we
want them to look like in the future our
district our future why metro area 20:48
aims to retain both the scale and
character of our settlements in small
towns more carefully managed new non
agricultural business activities in the
rural area provide options for the
management and future residential
housing in the rural and rural
residential areas so what do you think
let us know your thoughts and find out
more about the district development
strategy at Waimakariri govt TVNZ
[Applause]
you